foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
this is from Aaron says hello Matt my
best friend is in a relationship with
his girlfriend the mother of his child
will on occasion accuse him of cheating
and become so engulfed with rage that
she will yell at him call slash FaceTime
him until his phone dies she's also
thrown things at him and punched
scratched and bruised him on multiple
occasions all in arguments that in
retrospect they both admit we're
meaningless I worry for their soon to be
three-year-old child to grow up in an
environment where a parent becomes so
overcome with wrath that she resorts to
any means to get her point across I
think it's admirable to want to keep a
nuclear family for the sake of the child
my question is am I the a-hole for
wanting to limit my time around them
especially her she's told my girlfriend
lies about me and has asked her to keep
information from me on her behalf my
girlfriend and I are honest to one
another so those attempts do not work
but my girlfriend has a big heart and
negative energy can be an emotional
strain on her my friend says I'm being
rude and excessive for telling my girl
to not be around her when she doesn't
have to while I'm trying to maintain my
own relationship of course in situations
like family get-togethers or a wedding
we will attend and be cordial but in the
event that we want to go out to eat
alone I'll ask my girlfriend to politely
decline no you're not Dale you have
every right to decide who you want to be
around I always think it's funny when I
get these kinds of questions and um
maybe maybe I'm the wrong guy to answer
them because I'm anti-social so I I
never this is not anything that I ever
struggle with I wish you could see this
you're really struggling I never
struggle with this idea should I be
around somebody I don't want to be
around
no I don't now it's one thing if it's a
close family member if God forbid you're
married to someone that you go through a
period you don't want to be around them
uh something like that well then it's
like yeah you got now you have to work
through that you got to work on that
um you can't just cut somebody like that
out of your life but if it's outside of
that
um if it's someone it's an acquaintance
a friend someone you knew a long time
ago whatever and it's a negative
experience to be around them then you're
perfectly within your rights
to limit the time you spend around them
I know what I have to do but I don't
know if I have the strength to do it
you don't even have to you don't have to
wrestle with it very much uh people you
know there are people who are just
miserable like it sounds like this woman
is and they want to inflict that on
those around them and so your response
is I don't want to be around that
and so you limit that time you spin
around them and in fact even with family
members that might be the case too where
they want to inflict their misery on you
and so you don't want to be around them
because of it and that's all on them
that's not on you picture if you will
the perfect Summer Night the warm breeze
on your face as you Lounge in your
favorite chair outside the grill
sizzling with Juicy Burgers the aroma of
the food is irresistible your mouth
Waters as you wait for it to be cooked
to Perfection now imagine with this
perfect summer night would look like if
you went to turn on the grill and your
propane tank is empty it's a tragedy and
that's where my friends at cinch come in
and they can save the day and avert
tragedy cinch is a propane grill tank
Home Delivery Service they deliver
propane tanks right to your door cinch
delivers on your schedule doesn't
require any long-term commitment or
subscription plus delivery is completely
contactless which means you don't have
to wait around at home you can track the
order on the sin shop from anywhere
whether you're grilling for the sweet
baby gang camping with your family
lighting up your fire pit on a cold
summer night whatever it is cinches
propane delivery service ensures that
you have the fuel you need to make the
most of every moment and every night go
online to cinch.com or download their
app to order new customers can get their
first tank exchange for this 10 promo
code walls that's
cynch.com promo code walls this is a
limit time offer and you must live
within a cinched service area to redeem
it so visit cinch.com offer for details
from Ken says hi Matt I'm asking about
an event that did not happen as in my
wife told me that she almost broke up
with me while we were dating but four
anniversaries later and two beautiful
kids clearly she did not break up with
me the story of my first visit to meet
her parents came up and she said that
that night was almost the end for us
because her mom made meatloaf and I
barely ate any of it I can't stand
meatloaf and this was well known by my
wife at the time and she communicated
this to her parents but her mom made it
anyway I ate a few bites of it and fully
ate all the sides but apparently this
almost set my wife over the edge but I
did not choke down and risk the vomit
because her mom needed the gratification
of me eating her cooked meal I responded
the fact that I tried the meatloaf at
all was supposed to gain me extra points
since I was very upfront about my
dislike of me love and that there's no
reason for me to extra explain myself
since we're just talking about how I was
set up to fail but I was asked to
succeed anyway there's definitely a soul
here is it me for not extra trying to
choke down more meatloaf or my wife for
openly acknowledging it was a spot where
I was set up to fail well it's
definitely you I mean it's you 100 on on
so many different levels uh first of all
I'm a firm believer in you're a guest at
somebody's house you eat whatever is put
on your plate I don't care what it is I
don't care if they take their shoe off
their foot and put it on your plate and
say we're eating shoes tonight you eat
the damn shoe he's kidding right he's
not kidding I've told my kids this many
times they know whatever's put on your
plate you eat it and if we're at
somebody's house if we're a guest at
someone's house and they serve food on
your plate it's even more you damn well
better eat it I don't care what it is
and if it's bad if the person doesn't
know how to cook well then we're all
suffering together we are in this
together but you eat the food you're
also because meatloaf is delicious like
what do you mean you don't like meatloaf
what kind of man are you this is you
have fallen for this is a branding thing
okay the only problem meatloaf has the
reason meatloaf has a bad reputation and
a lot of kids don't like meatloaf is
because of the name like meat loaf oh
that seems gross at first blush right
it's just whoever came up with the name
for meatloaf didn't spend any time
thinking about it and all they they just
looked at it and said well it's uh looks
kind of like a loaf and it's meat
so it's meatloaf it I I think if we
called it some I don't even know we
could Workshop it but like come up with
come up with some French what is
Meatloaf in French call it that and uh
then I think everybody would agree that
obviously meatloaf is delicious so
you've fallen for anti-meatloaf
propaganda
um it's very I think it is unmanly to
not like Meatloaf uh it should be you
know it's a comfort food it's a classic
comfort food Meatloaf uh mashed potatoes
gravy what kind of man are you that you
don't enjoy that kind of food and then
on the third level you know this is at a
time when right you just you just
started dating you're trying to impress
this young lady her mom is making food
and you would actually get all skimpy in
eating and get squeamish oh I don't like
that it's I don't like meatloaf sorry do
you have a vegan substitute a vegan a
gluten-free vegan somehow your marriage
worked out and you have kids and
hopefully you you teach them to eat
their food unlike you but uh she would
have been justified in dumping you right
then on the spot I think it would have
been totally justified so unfortunately
you are the three times over eat
your food okay
[Music]
pictures of an egg
have some more chicken have some more
pie it doesn't matter if it's oil or
fried just eat it